we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
in the wake of the matt gates
allegations of
possible statutory rape and child sex
trafficking and so on and so forth
we had a great caller with advice this
is important advice this is important
advice for anybody in the audience
if you want to avoid being charged with
statutory rape
okay and i think most people would want
to avoid being charged with that
here is a caller explaining to you how
to do it take a listen
all right this is jane from pennsylvania
right there is one sure way for a man to
avoid
being charged with statutory rape if you
don't know her well enough to know
her correct age don't have sex with her
wow what a vote
uh i don't know why i love that caller i
think it's the delivery
and the accent and it's just absolutely
perfect
yeah that's good advice and now you know
there will be
you hear about these stories where um
one one the accused will say they lied
about their age they just lied
and you know the difference if i'm if
i'm
30 the difference between a 17 and an 18
year old
is not obvious and what am i going to do
check for id or something like that so
you'll you'll hear those stories but
generally speaking this is good advice
and
um i mean in most cases wouldn't you be
able to you know if you're
i i i don't even want to speculate but
the point is
you would learn the truth of someone's
life and like if they're going to high
school
rather than college or whatever you
would think
that these cases of i was really tricked
by someone claiming to be of a certain
age
those seem like they would be relatively
rare and i think that the advice there
from jane is is
quite good we've got a great bonus show
coming up for you today
we will talk about pro-tax billionaires
who are protesting
not in front of jeff bezos's house but
in front of jeff bezos's
many homes okay that's a protest that
protects millionaires are undertaking
number two the supreme court is
restricting police authority to enter
homes without a warrant
and we will talk about the circumstances
and number three
a new study from the world health
organization finds that
overwork has killed more than 745
000 people in a year this is why we do
our six month vacations
that we are so uh well known for um
you know this is a real issue and it's
more an issue in some countries than in
others
and we're going to talk about the
cultural aspect of it we're going to
talk about the physiological aspect of
it but uh
three-quarters of a million people in a
year
believed to have died from what is being
described as overwork
uh and we will talk about all of those
stories
and much more when i am joined by
producer pat
on today's bonus show we may even give
uh some awards out to the bonus show
uh today get instant access by becoming
a member at joinpacman.com
or becoming a patron at patreon.com
david pakman show patreon.com show i'll
see you on the bonus show